last time you guys were roasting me in
the comments because I made basically a
four minute tangent about my beard but
the haha is on you guys now because we
got ourselves an offer a sponsorship
offer from a real razor supply company
called supply they started the bidding
at 1k now it's official boys at least a
minimum of 1000 dollars will be going to
a charity we're gonna give it a 72-hour
window for this bidding war to continue
Friday I will be announcing the winner
of this competition the sponsorship will
go live a little bit after the wedding
and that's that pretty excited thousand
dollars minimum going to charity wait
actually supply just outbid themselves a
thousand and one dollars guys big brains
over it and supply how bidding
themselves now without further ado let's
get in to the actual show because I've
got a good one for you today this
investigation took so many twists and so
many turns once again we start with an
email from one of you but this time it's
anonymous but suffice it to say they
came to me with the rather incredible
story dare I say unbelievable story they
start talking to me about this fake guru
who supposedly took a hundred thousand
dollars from a lady that was supposedly
mentally diminished and then when she
called him out on his fraud he started
to harass her and I was like reading
this I was like there's no way but when
you actually go and look there's proof
the state of Vermont has been
investigating a fake guru known as
Patrick maza of evolution mentor you can
find him on Instagram and we'll be
talking more about him but the substance
of this case is absolutely in sane this
lady who will be remaining nameless got
solicited by mr. Massa for a
cryptocurrency mining scheme where they
were supposed to invest a hundred
thousand dollars and by late this is all
from a docket coming straight from the
government of Vermont now part of this
advertisement listen to this guy's
mister Maas apparently part of his
presentation featured a photograph of
himself with Pope Francis and other
celebrities and promising returns of 500
7% he further promised that you invest
$100,000 that's the extent of the work
you do
guaranteed zero risk in an additional
return of $900,000 on May 19 20 21 now
this lady is from Vermont and according
to this document she suffers from mental
health conditions which quote diminished
her mental capacity now she kind of
figures out hey maybe this is too good
to be true
so she files a fraud claim with the TD
Bank and filed complaints with the
Federal Trade Commission and Vermont
State Police as a result there that Bank
placed a hold on the fund and wouldn't
release them to maza maza gets pissed
off and he starts to threaten her
he first threatens to sue her if she
does not retract her fraud claim and
then goes after her children saying that
Carolyn Allison and Robert are in for a
rough ride due to your their fraudulent
actions we've spoken to our contacts
like James Madison have gotten
information on Carolyn we have contacts
so very clear threats
James Madison is a university I believe
that's what they're talking about
and apparently it continues to threaten
her and her family by telephone and
email this is just monstrous I don't
know what else to say
and actually the Secret Service is now
involved on or about June 2nd 2020 the
from the Vermont Department of Financial
Regulation received communications from
the United States Secret Service
regarding a Vermont resident and
people's customers who'd wired money to
Patrick Mazdas account at TD Bank in
Ontario so the Secret Service are
involved with this fake guru over in
Canada taking $100,000 from this lady
and then threatening her when she filed
fraud charges against what is clearly
fraud now a little bit more about Mazda
you can go to his page of course he's a
guru coach right of course he's got to
be and when you go to his page he's got
all these pictures with celebrities now
are these real pictures we don't know
but what we do know he definitively fake
is when he talks about what sales
authorities have to say and it's a bunch
of basically wringing endorsements of
him well actually I looked
the the source of those quote quote
endorsements because all these people at
Google are supposedly vouching for him
the VP at Google is vouching for him
another VP of Google's vouching form the
enterprise sales manager at Google's
vouching form except they're not those
are photoshopped recommendations from
LinkedIn he took him straight from
LinkedIn these people were publicly
endorsing someone else and this loser
decided to Photoshop his own name in
their impertinent
he's who they're talking about this guy
Patrick maza
is threatening people he's faking
documentation it's completely sick ok if
you want to know what I think now this
is where the plot thickens because one
thing that this says is that they met at
a Bob Proctor event which is sort of a
guru event and I wanted to learn more
about who this lady is that got you know
scammed etc first of all I found out who
she is I'll be keeping her nameless for
the sake of her privacy I think she's
been through far more than enough with
this guy harassing her but I find out
that she also is like a coach of some
kind and so I think to myself oh my gosh
that's so weird
fake guru get scammed by fake guru but
then I find another article another
report of the Secret Service supposedly
investigating this lady and her husband
so not only is Patrick Mazda the fake
guru getting investigated by the Secret
Service but apparently according to this
press release the Secret Service is
attempting to retrieve three million
dollars believed to have been sent to to
Peru Vermont residents as a result of a
misleading series of webinars what is
going on I've never seen The Secret
Service involved with anything and now
they're ostensibly involved with both of
these things now this is where I started
to get confused because you know while
you can find reports with the Vermont
state government for four maza
you can't find anything here and in fact
I couldn't find any reports anywhere but
this one news website that I'd never
heard of 3w news about this event and I
thought wow three million dollars is a
lot the Secret Service being involved is
a lot and there's only one person who's
really talking about it
this
Mike Smith at the bottom and this is
weird guys it's important to never trust
things that face value you always got to
go a level deeper and this is always why
I go oh my gosh I want to learn more
about this I need to kind of vet all
this information this is the craziest
story ever like these people are
scamming and then they get scammed by
this cryptocurrency but they're both
getting investigated by the secret
service like what is going on so at the
bottom it says contact Mike Smith of M
Smith gmail.com or at M Smith reports on
Facebook and Twitter
so I look him up on Twitter but I can't
find him so I thought to myself hmmm
that's weird so I look him up on
Facebook I can't find any Mike Smith
under Mike Smith reports
so I email him on Gmail at M Smith at
gmail.com and this the email bounces as
in there is no email address to be
delivered to so I'm like huh that's
really weird for a reporter to not have
any actual like social media that's very
strange and I'm like looking at this and
it's published after all of this stuff
is happening and when I'm looking up the
names of these people who are getting
harassed by maza all these things about
them being scams are coming up but
they're all from a bunch of anonymous
websites where there's daxing Mazdas
victims so they're saying you know these
gurus are scammers and here's their
phone number here's their email address
here's their whatever and so I start
going to these things and whenever
there's an email address listed I'll
just email them so for example one of
these supposed complaints which is once
again published super recently and after
Patrick Mazda got in all this trouble
it's complaining about you know this
this couple that has basically got it
gotten him in all this trouble and it's
saying it's posed it's posting their
public information and then it's saying
if anyone's pursuing legal action
against them please email me at Coyne
poppy 82 at gmail.com so I email him and
guess what that email address doesn't
exist either so guys we can't know
definitively what's going on here so I'm
gonna make I'm gonna have to hazard a
few guesses and give you my opinion of
what is going on here the fact that all
this bad
press is all of a sudden coming out
right after you know Patrick Mazda gets
in all this trouble and he's threatening
to harass them I think this is part of
their harassment do we know this for a
fact no these these articles I don't
believe they're real this thing about
The Secret Service is trying to retrieve
three million dollars from this couple
yeah I don't believe it at all because
the the reporter who supposedly has all
this information you know doesn't exist
this article if it were based on actual
facts would be all over the news I mean
the facts of it are crazy
it's accusing this couple of having ties
with the Gambino crime family of taking
three million dollars at the Secret
Service investigating them it would be
all over the news if it were real but
the fact that it just appears one time
on this obscure news site and then there
are a bunch of other anonymous
complaints popping up where the emails
aren't real and they're daxing the
people it makes me think it's all part
of the harassment so now we have the
fact that this poor couple who has
gotten a hundred thousand dollars taken
away from them now is getting their kids
are being harassed
apparently at their university is being
harassed this person is a diminished
mental health
these salacious defamatory articles are
coming out and we don't know who wrote
them we can speculate but we don't know
who wrote them to be clear I don't know
the legal reasons I don't know but what
an awful thing to happen I can't believe
we uncovered this and I just wanted to
say thank you to the copies little army
for once again putting me on to these
incredible stories
I look forward if there's any
developments in this story I will of
course come come forward with that I did
contact Patrick maza and asked him if he
wanted to comment on the whole story he
didn't respond but ultimately guys I am
disgusted you might think that I'd get
used to this stuff but know this stuff
constantly shocks me anyway guys thanks
for watching stay safe out there it's a
crazy world catch you guys later and
don't forget to smash like and subscribe
thank you
[Music]
[Music]